okay now what now what okay well let's
go with the Kings gambit or not Wow okay
this is definitely feeling like a first
here okay some things to know I need
only move this night in order to Castle
kingside like that and then my king ends
up here my rook ends up here and we move
forward what do you do to start control
the center I'm thinking about moving one
of these for I'm also thinking about
what is unprotected nothing's
unprotected I could see this guy being
unprotected soon after the night moves
but that's about it on in the center
this pawn in the center this pawn in the
center I like this as a start after all
that I think this is a good one
controlling one of the four center
squares moving any one of these four
pawns cdef will contribute in some way
to either the occupation or control or
both of one of one of these squares at
least one of these squares so now what
what should black be doing as a response
playing the mimicking game with c5
saying you know what I'm going to play
be five instead to control this right
now if something isn't done I could be
playing D for having to pawn side by
side not a bad idea at all from here
does my night really have a better
square than g3 probably not so it's the
verdict on that night the verdict is get
them out get them out this night on the
other hand maybe wants to be tucked
behind this deep on not really a big fan
of going here to obstruct any of my
Center ponds if I do play here it's
going to be quite temporary if I could
say to myself this is a hole boom boom
get
they're right away or um what else I'll
probably want to do similar with my beep
on otherwise my queen is dead to the
game however I'm going to be a bit more
aggressive and press forward two squares
challenge this pond get to a position
where maybe I could open up the B file
in my rook springs to life or maybe I
could push forward and gain a tempo at
some point on a piece should they end up
on one of these two squares I think more
possibilities are present by having the
pond on be opposed to just on be4
opposed to be three what else what else
is the scoop here dark square Bishop out
I'm really thinking about some queenside
expansion or 0 or this what about this
diagonal is open towards the King so
there's a bishop check I think that
could turn out to be inconvenient to
black Bishop check if the bishop blocks
we exchange bishops I helped blackout
development wise a little bit but long
term I could establish a pond on b5 and
then try and get one of these pesky
nights to that c 6 square if there's no
lights crab bishops on the board to
follow up with b5 and then get a night
there somehow that's what I would like
to do Bishop a4 there's also a 93 to
hear I think this is more to the point
let's see how black first responds okay
so now the bishop can't move not not at
least without allowing me to have that
King gone castled black is ready to
castle on the next move but what about
oh i play my night here that's probably
uncomfortable although that's probably
not good if i play my night no no no it
might be something to it night here
threatening to win this pond actually
I'm not going to do that I was concerned
about maybe a bishop coming here doing
two things one hitting this pond a
second time in two threatening maybe to
play here with the with a fork if my
night is on f5 of course I could be I
was threatening to take this pond with
check and then if the King goes here I
could go maybe to the edge with my night
but I don't know I like this a bit
better my opponent is watching over f5 I
think that's a very good idea my night
on the edge I think is good if g6 is
played and I play to g7 to give check
after King FA is my night trapped might
not be trapped because I could follow up
with Bishop here but I don't really want
to be tethered to the defense of one of
my pieces these guys are not going to be
so happy my queen and Bishop with just
watching out a night watching out over a
night on g7 what I could do is you know
after g6 I could go elsewhere with my
knight and say you know what if your
pawn is on g6 your night doesn't get to
play and maybe later I could be
considering Bishop beast be too yeah
Bishop to be too and putting pressure on
that night for a second time and maybe
that night would turn out to be lost
so now I
okay two-minute warning approximately
there will be a tournament coming up
soon very soon in about one half hour so
there's some weaknesses here what does
the pond doing what is it not doing its
not watching over this and I could
attack it so let's attack it this is a
problem the bishop is no longer going to
be in a spot to watch over if the pond
pushes this night is going to be licking
his chops at the juicy juicy square d 5
I could also consider just planting my
night here but I like just being able to
rely upon d5 it's a nice cozy square
it's a support point already by my see
pond and keep in mind what this earlier
moved in it was watching over f5 all of
a sudden these squares light up both of
them are accessible to both nights well
not both nights anyhow both squares are
available to my nights that move I
didn't consider ah I didn't consider
that one okay well I really don't want
to move my night so what do you do if
you don't want to move your night you be
stubborn be stubborn you say I don't
want to move that night and this Queen
has no business being in the center of
the board like this with so many minor
pieces and my next move is going to be
to flush this Queen elsewhere remove the
defenders the plan get out of their
queen remove the defender I really don't
want to ever be caught in a situation
like that you set yourself up for the
tactic of fill in the blank who knows it
when one of your pieces is tethered to
the defense of another piece or upon you
set yourself you're setting yourself up
for the tactic of name it who's going to
get it typed first and twitch if you
happen to be tuned in and listening name
that word yes with the fastest fingers
mr. windmill 100 if you're real issah
nning to this the unrep the not live
version that word that has been typed in
the chat is deflection and there will
swear several typing that just anand and
stumble B and nuke
ok
well
I could take this guy but I'm not going
to he's not he's that he's a bad guy
anyhow he's obstructed he can't be too
happy all these ponds are stopping him
from being active I'm going to throw
this check in or this one I like this
one I'm gonna go with this one just give
a check get my other night here I could
give this check first let me do that the
King goes here I come back and give a
check or maybe take here yeah I probably
do that let's let's get rid of this
Bishop that's definitely a more valuable
one and get here with check and then
well just want to trade a little bit
more let's get rid of this and then take
here and it's soon to be looking like
okay well actually we're down in time I
forgot that part okay good game in Lopez
let's hit that rewind button see if
there's something else we could do be
doing with our our setup I think your
response of this is fine it's going with
some symmetry I would consider b5 just
as I played be four here maybe you could
be more aggressive and i've said this i
said this in another stream when it
comes to the fisher random I've said
that when it comes to pawn moves look to
have them doing more than just one thing
so I think with your beep on push it's
doing more than one thing it's allowing
the Queen to come out the bishop to come
out but by going an additional square
forward it's allowing for the rope to
maybe work right away the B file can
open up in a blink we're exchanging uh
from the standard position what we would
call a night pond for a bishop on and in
the beginning of the game the central
pawns you could start to regard as being
well as having let's say a point value
of
one and as you move outward you could
consider the bishop ponds as being a
value 0 point 9 and then the Knights
point eight if you want to really get
mathy with it so anyhow you would be
having if you did a knight pun move like
this with b5 and challenge the bishop on
what would really be going on you have a
point 8 pun challenging a point 9 pun
anyhow that might be getting a bit too
mapping but it's something that I do in
my own games and anyhow I think it's
purposeful to look into it from this set
up seeing how you I already have a rook
on b8 and well maybe taking into account
that i have this diagonal available i
could shoot right out here give checked
your king maybe bring your night out
like I did or get this other night and
get castled it's going to be better I
think it's a bit uncomfortable to deal
with the bishop comin off and this and
this diagonal and it's it's tough to
start to defend now this is this is
quite tricky I night min the Queen
converging on this so don't open up this
diagonal so quickly consider be five
instead of b6 and maybe get up both your
nights out and get King side castle okay
you are typing my way thank you very
much you are welcome